礼！
こんにちは！　はじめしゃちょーと
アバンティーズ　そらちぃと、ツリメと、リクヲと、エイジです。
さとちんです
あれ？
腐ィッシャーズ　シルクです、ンダホです、マサイです、ぺけたんです。
さとちん　です。
はい、でここにいるYouTuberは全員非常に甘い
ｗｗｗ
うん。
お前ら、ちゃんと自覚しているとだろうと思うが、
まだまだ、動画に対する気持ちが足りない
今日の企画は、
ｗ
いや、そう笑うな。
笑ってはダメだ。
いいか。
ハイテンションと言う物を、まだまだ甘く見ている世代が、やっぱ、いるから
もっと、ハイテンションというものを、もっともっとこう、真面目に
心から、真摯に、俺表現したい。
今笑っただろ💢
誰も
いいだろう
というわけで、今日は、ハイテンション大会をやろうと思う
アバンティーズ各1名、フィッシャーズ各1名、
さとちん...1名
ｗｗｗ
おぃ！！笑うな💢💢（正確に聞き取れません）
そういうとこだぞ
甘いぞ
ｗｗ
www　　あまっ　　ｗｗｗ
各メンバー一人ずつが出て、ほかの観客全員に対して、演舞を行う
その演舞で全員が笑いを取られたら
それは、真のハイテンション
演技者が笑っちゃうと、それはもう、事前、
完全に自分ももう、笑っちゃっているから
甘えてんだよ、そう、自分に対して
どこもとスティックに（聞き取れない）
本気でハイテンションで行くことが、真のハイテンションということで
では、Fischer's　だれがいく？
OK.　シルク
アバンティーズ　だれがいく？
そらちぃ
さとちん　さん　だれがいく？
ほかのメンバーは審判　ちゃんと笑わないよう、いてほしい
いくぞーー！！
おすっ！！
おらぁぁあ！　よしぃぃぃい！
気合入れろーー
行きます
（はじめしゃちょーの震える声）
（はじめしゃちょーが自分の体をたたく音）
（謎の雄たけび？？）
（観客の笑い）
ずるいでしょ。今の
わぁぁ！！
（観客の拍手）
（観客席からの笑い）
よしみんな！！笑わずに行こう！
始まるよ
オス！！
（観客の爆笑）
みんなとは、関わったことないけども
これからね、
（観客の笑い）
絡みを
強くしていきたいと
こういうことをするのは、ほんとに、初めてです。
ということで
ハイテンションなりたいと思います
行きます
（はじめしゃちょーがよくやる「ポーツクツ」っていうやつを全力でやるさとちん）
（じわるｗｗ）
以上です
（観客、倒れるほどの爆笑）
ま、まぁ、素晴らしい
（観客、盛大な拍手）
最後だ、これが
エントリーナンバー4番　　アバンティーズのそらちぃです
とびきりのハイテンションをお届けします
（そらちぃ　謎の叫び声を上げる　の巻）
（観客　しける）
レリゴ～レリゴ～
謎の叫び
あれ？あれ？あれなあに？
ジェットコースター？あれ！ジェットコースター？
わゎわゎわゎわゎわゎわゎわゎわゎわゎわゎわゎわゎわゎわゎわゎわゎ
（観客　笑う）
素晴らしい　（拍手）